تلقينا أخبارًا عن غارة جوية أوكرانية بطائرة بدون طيار
على مدينة رئيسية في غرب روسيا منذ
حوالي نصف ساعة قال حاكم إقليمي إن
طائرة بدون طيار ضربت إدارة مبنى
في مدينة كورسك مما تسبب في أضرار،
في الوقت نفسه تقول أوكرانيا إن دفاعاتها الجوية
ضربت 14 من أصل 15 روسيًا  طائرات بدون طيار يوم
السبت تراقب نانوباشير
التطورات في أوكرانيا وتنضم إلينا
من لندن، لذا الآن أولاً، ما الذي
نتعلمه أكثر عن أحدث الهجمات،
حسنًا، يبدو أن هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار ضد
المواقع الأوكرانية التي تشتري
القوات المسلحة الروسية أصبحت
حدثًا منتظمًا على الرغم من أنه كما
ذكرت  أن الغالبية العظمى من هذه
الجولة الأخيرة من الهجمات يوم السبت
صدتها الدفاعات الجوية الأوكرانية، حيث
أسقطت 14 من أصل 15 طائرة بدون طيار، ولكن
ليس فقط هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار التي
نشهدها على مدار نهاية هذا الأسبوع، فقد
شهدنا العشرات من الهجمات الجوية
بالإضافة إلى الهجمات الصاروخية التي شنتها القوات المسلحة الروسية
على المواقع الأوكرانية مما تسبب في
أضرار جسيمة للبنية
التحتية المدنية أيضًا، وفي الواقع،
علمنا في
منطقة زابا ريجيا أن شخصًا واحدًا على الأقل
قُتل بنيران المدفعية الروسية خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية.
في هذه الأثناء،
ورد أن شخصًا آخر قُتل في هرثستون نتيجة
للقصف الروسي، لذلك ما زلنا
نرى التأثير المدني الحقيقي لهذه
الهجمات الروسية، لكن على الرغم من هذه
الهجمات، يقول مسؤولو الدفاع الأوكرانيون إنهم
يحرزون تقدمًا على طول
الخطوط الأمامية، وأن وحداتهم
تحتفظ بمواقعها.  مواقع صامدة
في العديد من مناطق الخطوط الأمامية الرئيسية خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع، علمنا من
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين أن وحداتهم في
كل من ليمان ومارينكا صدت
الهجمات الروسية في ميوان وباكموت،
ويقال إن
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية أحبطت التقدم الروسي هناك،
وفي الوقت نفسه يتم تنفيذ ثماني غارات جوية.  العمليات المذكورة التي
نفذتها القوات الجوية الأوكرانية
ضد أصول تعتبر ذات أهمية حيوية للقوات
المسلحة الروسية في أوكرانيا، ومن
الواضح أن هناك بعض العلامات على التقدم على طول
الخطوط الأمامية في شرق أوكرانيا